my name is Paris I'm the CEO of chitin
your company selling sample and si
technologies that are used and analyzed
genetic information I'm answering Wendy
uh comments questions what do you want
to be remembered for stored at some
point in time in the future we are
engaged in a very early phase of an
industrial revolution our solutions are
used in the gene goldrush to identify
new genetic information and also to make
use of that genetic information in
healthcare for instance but also into
many other areas of today's Knives our
our culture therefore is one way of
creating something new of coming forward
with groundbreaking new technologies
that we want to make so easy to use they
can be used in every type of household
and thereby create enormous benefits for
healthcare not only in the industrial
world developing world in the area of
food safety also availability in the
area of pharmaceutical research to get
federal drugs to the market and and
science as well to be able to get
further breakthroughs in this
tremendously